In this video, I want to talk about the stakeholders,
in other words, who you'll be working with.
Because creating a Power BI data model and
the subsequent reports is as much about people as it is about data.
Who your stakeholders will be will depend on your organization size and structure,
and their stage of Power BI adoption.
It also depends on the size of your data modeling team.
How many people will be engaged in data modeling and reporting in report building,
which can be anything from a one-person job to a massive team effort.
I've sketched out a few common scenarios,
though yours will probably fall somewhere in the middle.